become wealthy the moment you decide you
are because you will realize at some
point that money will buy you freedom
will not buy you happiness
i was talking to an entrepreneur the
other day and we were talking about
living expenses and one of the things
that a lot of our portfolio companies
struggle with is when to decide to start
spending money right it's very difficult
because we a lot of times as
entrepreneurs especially those that that
grow their businesses many times they've
been taught not to spend money which i
think is the right you know lesson
overall to get to get started right if
you define that as like the optimal
convert material wealth you know on the
flip side there's also some people who
struggle to ever get ahead and they're
always living paycheck to paycheck even
when they have a lot of money and i know
i have some friends who uh you know
they're in their 50s and uh have always
made very very high incomes and have
spent virtually every dollar and now
they regret it and so i don't think
there's anything wrong with spending all
the money that you have i do think that
it is not ideal for material wealth
accumulation if that is the goal but you
may enjoy your life that way so it's
really i think a balancing act between
those things and so i thought it might
be fun to make a video um about how my
living expenses changed from you know
dollar zero uh to now we do you know
over 100 million dollars a year at
acquisition.com um and if you're new to
the channel i make these videos just
because i want to help and i hope that
these things can help you get to three
million dollars more so potentially
partner with your business and help you
get to 30 and beyond all right but
otherwise i have no coaching mentorships
or anything like that that i sell and i
make these videos because i enjoy doing
it okay let's dive in so you know season
one here was alex quitting his job and
sleeping on the floor all right and so i
tried to write out each of these phases
or seasons of my life kind of like the
outcome the income and kind of the the
expenses i was incurring at the time all
right so i slept on the gym floor so i
had no rent besides my business rent but
i know personal rent uh my car payment i
was not existing because i had my car in
cash um and i actually only lived
exclusively on the cash sales from the
business that was actually my living
money which for me was a combination of
eating in and out in chipotle and that
was it uh my accountant actually told me
that my i did done 500 over 500
transactions at chipotle uh that first
year and he was like that's insane i was
like well i don't buy groceries and i
don't cook so i just i ate out always
and that worked out for me so it was
actually for me cheaper than all the
time and i just stayed at work and i
slept there and that was kind of it
right and so anyways even during that
time i was able to increase my income to
about 15 000 a month but i i tend to be
very security driven and i've noticed
that by myself so i like to make a lot
more than i'm spending right and the
reason i'm making this video too is that
like some people will see us you know
fly private or they'll see us eat out
you know many many many or every night
of the week and think oh that's what i
should do now i should emulate that i
think i wanted to actually show kind of
the come up of what kind of expenses you
know expenses income ratio looked like
for me over the last 10 years uh to
hopefully you know provide some clarity
uh for those of you who at least are
trying to emulate the path um and if
you're not then don't emulate this path
but this is what worked for me okay now
at this point i had two partners into
the scene and we stopped taking
dividends and we started investing in
the growth of the business overall so
you can see here that's when i went from
you know one to six gyms and i really
took no dividends in that period of time
and i had saved this up for about six
months so i had about seventy thousand
dollars total saved up after taxes from
that first you know six to nine months
of doing business and at that point that
was it and i lived on that for three
years that cash lasted me for three
years which is again probably why i'm so
security driven um because i know what
it's like to live on nothing and so my
my car was still in cash so i had no car
payments and i did up my lifestyle uh to
renting a room and uh it wasn't actually
me running a room for contacts i
actually had a true roommate so it was a
house there were seven people lived in
the house and i split one room and so
this was in southern california and my
rent was i think it was 700 a month it
might have been 400. it was 400 to 700
in there and it was a house in costa
mesa and i literally had another guy who
slept in there with me and we split it
all right so mind you like i'm
reinvesting all my cash in growing these
in this business but my personal
expenses were virtually zero the only
thing i spent money on was going out to
ebola and that was it right that was
literally all i spent money on and i had
this shared room okay now i did that for
three years all right so i can say three
years really easily but it took three
years of my life uh of this little
season here now the next season that
happened was i bought a condo and i
bought a condo because i really liked
the condo i thought it was you know well
priced and whatnot and uh i lived there
for a very short period of time and then
i realized that i could rent it for 3
500 a month so that's what i ended up
renting the condo for and then that's
when layla and i started doing gym
turnarounds so you used to fly around
and do these launches right and so these
launches at that time from business
perspective got us to about 200 300 a
month now that was uh revenue my income
was still very very low uh and that's
because again i didn't take
distributions because i didn't learn
that lesson yet all right so for those
of you who are like taking notes at home
there's multiple periods of those who
know my story i've lost everything in
between here multiple times and so that
is why i'm so big on taking
distributions as you grow because at the
end of the day risk is a real thing and
um i had spent years of my life building
something only to lose it and i didn't
want to make that mistake again and so
this was yet again another one of those
mistakes where i did um and i did these
turnarounds and i lived at the extended
stay here for 1800 a month all right so
my rent expense was 1800 a month uh we
lived uh we had a car that we owned in
cash which was the prius during this
period of time and that was it that was
the only expenses was the extended stay
and then us eating you know chipotle and
stuff and layla was uh kind enough to
deal with me eating chipotle during this
entire period of time and so we got the
business about 200 300 100 000 a month
there was a bunch of logistical issues
with the business it was low margin
there's a lot of operational complexity
i was learning right so then from there
um we said you know what maybe we should
settle down and that's when we switch to
having sales teams fly out and do this
stuff uh you know on our on our behalf
and do the gym turnouts and we could
stay central so that's where we moved to
albuquerque because we had friends in
albuquerque that we wanted to learn from
and our rent there was 200 a month okay
uh the car we owned in cash which was
prius so aka hashtag mozymobiles those
of you who are you know valuing uh your
business over your uh personal
expenditures and we ate out uh eight out
out once a week and this is actually
when we switched to um to meal prepping
excuse me so uh leila started cooking
because we had a kitchen uh that was
like regular and it wasn't just like an
extended steak kitchen so she started
cooking which was awesome and uh we ate
out once a week for like a date night
because that's what we believed what we
had to do then was have a date night
which we have since uh changed the way
we do things but at that time that was
the one kind of big expense of the week
because we would eat out car was in cash
1200 a month was our rent and here's
what's crazy during this period of time
the business went from the turnaround
business at 300 000 a month to 1.5
million a month all right and these were
my living expenses so i was saving and
this is really saving i was adding a
million dollars to my personal bank
account every month all right uh and by
i i mean we all right and so this is
when we started to really create a lot
of wealth very quickly and mind you like
we didn't live on a lot of money still
all right and i think when we had about
i wanna say we had like shoot i wanna
say we had four to six million saved up
after taxes at this point and that's
when in cash we bought a 1.8 million
house we bought the 120 million dollar
house in cash uh in austin which uh was
a really good deal at the time for that
particular house we still split one car
it was she owned in cash and this car
now got upgraded it was an i8 which was
a gift from clickfunnels for being an
affiliate um so i got the car for free
and they basically paid us to buy the
car it doesn't matter but the point is i
didn't have i didn't have car payments
um for the car and this time we still
ate out actually less frequently than in
albuquerque because we were like super
intense in work mode this is where we
overindexed on trying to build the
enterprise and build the business during
that period of time and um i don't want
to say i regret that i think it was a
necessary lesson i think we did not have
nearly as much fun as we probably could
have but layla and i were so afraid of
losing what we had built and so you know
we it was just like we just didn't want
to mess it up and so we just wanted to
work all the time because we were just
so afraid it was very fear drivens
though now two or three years in uh at
this point we brought we uh we bought an
additional car which was a bentley um i
talked to bradley and i talked to
berkustio friends of ours and uh they
were like dude you gotta spend some
money and i was like alright so we
bought a fancy car and i realized
quickly that we uh didn't care and so we
sold it within six months we lost money
on the car and uh we were happier for it
and so uh it's just we realized it just
didn't matter to us it just sat in the
driveway and getting uh an expensive car
fixed we had a teenager ding the thing
the bumper and it was you know in the
shop for three months of the six and it
was ultimately just a pain in the ass
now that being said still during this
period of time uh you know the the
bentley was the only really expensive
thing we bought the house was in cash so
i had no house payment the car was in
cash there no car payment and the only
real expenses we had it at that that
period of time was eating out one to two
times a month that was literally it all
right and during that time our revenue
increased from 1.5 million a month to
over four million a month in that period
of time and our wealth continued to uh
to grow because everything that was in
excess from the income perspective just
poured straight into our savings all
right so that was for context during
that period of time i think we
accumulated around i want to say 30
million dollars after taxes in in cash
and assets or you know cash equivalents
things like that and so it was really
just savings right we didn't sell
anything at that point that's kind of
where we're at at that chapter all right
now at that point now mind you this was
like cash stuff there's the equities in
the business that obviously uh were
worth more than that um but that was
just straight dividends and i think an
important part there is like i i learned
to take dividends because i realized
that i was giving myself an excuse by
reinvesting every dollar of cash flow
into the business which a lot of times
meant that i just wasn't really focused
on profitability and um i think that
sometimes that's a business strategy
it's very rarely the right one um and a
lot of times just having a sustainable
growth path where you can de-risk
yourself by taking cash off the table
because let's say uh covid happened for
example and you know our companies had
gone down which they did and thankfully
we had very strong businesses that were
able to sustain that even though they
were in heavily hit industries this gave
us a very good peace of mind to know
that we could cash for the company if we
needed to and we could keep everything
alive for as long as it lasted and you
know we thought it was going to be 12
weeks and then it was two years right
and so that's why i'm a big fan of
de-risking and living cheap now you're
like well that's not living cheap alex
thing is that relative to my income and
this is why i wanted to make these
videos for context right yes we lived in
a 1.8 million dollar house and yes you
know we sold the house for 4 million two
and a half years later like so it was an
expensive it was a nice house in a nice
neighborhood but like we could buy our
house in cash every month off of our
income all right so like this is what i
feel like is lost sometimes in the
podcasts and interviews that i talk
about and sometimes like oh you eat now
you eat out oh you private and it's like
yes but like i'm so security driven and
i just want to convey that i'm not
saying you have to be i'm saying this is
work for me all right and so we were
able to accumulate about 30 million
bucks in cash between like real estate
and stocks i would say like non-business
equities um or non-public market
equities uh during that period of time
all right now after that um those of you
some of you know is that in 2021 uh we
sold everything so we sold our three
businesses we sold two cars we sold the
house we sold everything actually we
sold one car we were going to sell the
other car i think we kept it so excuse
that so that should just be one we were
planning on selling two we sold one was
the belly sorry to interrupt if you guys
have been joining the content and have
any questions about what you've seen so
far go ahead and drop the questions in
the comments below so that i can answer
them in future videos and provide more
value to you keep enjoying the video
continue all right so we sold everything
so we had no personal assets all right
we had business assets and investment
assets we know personal assets at that
time and so then we started running a
condyle the one that we are currently in
for 15 grand a month we spend about 15
000 a month on food and eating out we
don't cook much and that's just from a
time perspective and it's also for us
the end of the day is kind of like where
we unwind and so we work from pretty
early morning until about four or five
o'clock then we got to dinner at six we
get back home at 7 30. lately and i
probably watch a show and then we go to
bed and we do it all over again and so
that's that's our day that's what we do
it might be like that's really boring
yeah probably i don't know we like it
and so that's what we do so we spend 15
15 a month on food probably fifteen
thousand dollars a month on travel i
will say this i flew private more during
this season
that's a plane
there you go there's my plane uh
we flew private more during this season
than we do now and that's because we
found something that i think uh gives us
confers from a benefit to cost ratio
many of the advantages of private uh but
it's uh it's public so we actually fight
jsx now for anything that is on the west
coast which is basically like
semi-private travel it's cool it's like
you know you can have like three to you
know 15 other people on the plane with
you and you and it has all the same
benefits of private which is you roll up
straight to the plane 10 minutes before
it takes off you literally get right
into the plane and then it lands and
then you walk straight to a car uh so it
just saves so much time and it's
marginally more expensive than a normal
ticket i think some of the tickets are
like 200 to 400 bucks it's not expensive
and so we have opted to do it to flying
on that airline rather than private um
and this is not sponsored by jsx but i
you know i would endorse them because
they're great and so we stopped we
stopped flying private because you know
spending 50 000 on a plane flight if i
can get basically the same benefit for
400 uh is worth it and so again this is
one of those like we flew private
because it saved us time and it turned
travel from a negative into a positive
but jsx i think accomplishes all that
and i never cared about having other
people on the plane i just cared about
getting places faster not having to get
hassled um and jsx accomplishes that so
i mean we're we we pretty much always
fly those now um everywhere we go and
almost if anything uh we we try and fly
places where they go which is wonderful
and you know during this period of time
where we're currently at you know uh
acquisition.com i say in the videos you
know we're doing over a hundred million
dollars a year but right now we're over
150 but just for the sake of you know
not making the number change every time
the businesses grow we grew from about
seven million dollars a month to uh 13
million a month between the portfolio
companies in that period of time and so
i show this to show that you know i
don't think our lifestyles have
increased at the proportion that our
income has and i think that's because
layla are both very security driven um
as individuals and that works for us and
i want to have kind of one final point
that i'll make here that uh hopefully
you can take away from this is that if
the goal is material wealth accumulation
then the lower your personal expense is
the more you will accumulate right and
your peace of mind will be predicated on
the ratio between your income and your
expenses right if you can make enough in
a month or a year to give yourself
another multiple years of living then
you go towards your fu number as fast as
possible so you know there's two
variables there how much you make and
how much you spend now at some point
people are like well i'd like to
increase my expenditures i think that's
natural and i think that's normal and i
think the thing that i would push
against which is why we have uh you know
a hashtag that went pretty uh pretty
viral which is mosey mobiles uh we'll
probably have mosey mansions too i'll
probably start that one uh maybe i'll
show an image of what our 1200 apartment
looked like but it's it's really less
about living cheap and more about
spending money on the things that you
value rather than what society's told us
to value right and so for me the equity
growth of my businesses i valued more
than having a lambo or having a bentley
and for me i just don't get a lot of
value from it now some people might and
that's okay i just think that it's
really good to think consciously am i
buying this because i want status from
other people or because i really think
that this thing converts value right
same thing with flying private for
example at least for us the decision
calculus has changed recently just
because i just discovered this um for
the last few months we've been flying
jsx and honestly i love it it's great i
you know i the benefits of value ratio
uh has diminished now that i have an
alternative that is you know 1 100th of
the price of private and confers almost
all the benefits that i enjoyed i say
this to say i am all about wealth and
wealth is the ratio between income and
expenses and the peace of mind that you
have from knowing that you have enough
and so for me my goal was to get to
enough as fast as possible so that i
could feel that peace of mind um
everything we do now is just for love of
the game which is why the podcast is
called the game which is why i make
these videos and just to see like what
would it look like to get to a billion
uh because that sounds really exciting
and epic and fun and at the same time as
i'm super invested and motivated to get
there i'm okay if we never do uh and i
don't even want to say that because i do
100 believe that we're gonna get there
but it's it's really about playing the
game and i think that that has been i
think the goal if i have for mozzie
nation is that everyone can get to a
point where they're just playing the
game for the love of the game not for
the lambo or for the mansion or for the
whatever because i can tell you that
those are moments and those are fleeting
and so i think it's much more of a
process of becoming rather than
obtaining and i think that if we can
make that switch we get to experience a
lot of the benefits of the wealth
because wealth occurs or you become
wealthy the moment you decide you are
because you will realize at some point
that money will buy you freedom will not
buy you happiness and so if the goal is
you know first the goal is freedom short
but then you're free to experience the
feelings that you have and you'll
realize that it was not that thing but
it can absolutely decrease pain and
inconvenience in your life and so i can
obviously i am somebody who's gone after
material wealth accumulation in my life
so i don't want to say that like it's
not something that i find interesting
fun and stimulating i don't even know
what i would do if this game didn't
exist but it's really just to take pause
and think like are these things that i'm
buying really adding more value than the
price that i'm incurring to purchase
them and i think many times people
purchase things without thinking that
extra taking that extra second to pause
and say like am i really getting 500
value from this shoe am i really getting
2 000 from this belt am i really getting
xyz now you can do this relative to your
income right like it's not unreasonable
to live on a million dollars a year if
you make 15 million a year right it's
not it's actually less and here's what's
crazy it's less to live on a million
dollars a year when you make 15 than it
is to live on 100 when you make 400
right it's about the ratio between
income and expenses and so we can
control our expenses into it
and also we can control our income based
on getting more skills which is why i've
been a very loud advocate for spending
as much of your extra dollars on
acquiring more skills so that you can
increase your capacity to earn and when
you do that you can accelerate towards
that wealth discrepancy between income
and expenses at a faster rate and then
ultimately achieve the peace of mind
that i think most of us are after
anyways mosey nation um i love you guys
i appreciate you i don't deserve this
audience that you guys have come
together you guys are amazing and i just
i'm so grateful that this channel and
the other you know
social media accounts and things like
that thank you guys for all the support
you guys are just awesome i just didn't
even know so many of people like you
know me existed out there and it
definitely makes me feel less alone so
appreciate you guys keep being awesome
and i'll see you guys in the next money
making madness video we have on this
channel mozination if you enjoyed that
video smash the subscribe button and hit
the little notification bell the reason
for that is because i don't actually
have a cadence when i make these videos
so if you want to make sure you don't
miss the next one that comes out go
subscribe notify and i'll see you the
next one
you